I'm now just going to review
a couple of more projectile
motion problems, because I
really want you to understand
this as deeply as possible.
Because the rest of physics
that we do and the rest of
mechanics, a lot of it really
just depends on your
understanding of projectile
motion.
And hopefully this will
be intuitive for
you after some point.
Let's just go back to a
problem we did before.
Let's say that I'm at the top
of a building and I take a
rock or a ball-- and I don't
recommend that you do this--
and I drop it.
I dropped the ball.
And let's say that I know that
the building is, well I don't
know, let's say it's a
very tall building.
Well let's say it's
not too tall.
Let's say we're throwing
it from the 10th story.
So it's roughly 100 feet, or
that's about 30 meters, right?
So the ball is going to go 30
meters down, so the change in
distance is going to be minus
30 meters, right?
The ball is going to
fall 30 meters.
Now if I ask you, hey you, how
fast is that ball going to be
right before it hits
the ground?
Well I could rewrite all the
formulas, but I think
hopefully you know them by now,
but there's two kind of
interesting formulas
we might use.
I'll also show you maybe how to
do this more intuitively.
But there's vf squared is equal
to vi squared plus 2ad.
And then there is and this is
2 times delta d, right?
Whoops, plus 2a times
change in distance.
Sometimes I'll just write
that as distance.
And then there was change in
distance is equal to the
initial velocity times time
plus acceleration time
squared over 2.
And the there were
the other ones.
Change in distance is rate times
time, and velocity is
acceleration times time, and
you know about all average
velocity, et cetera,
et cetera.
So one of these formulas I
think might strike you as
immediately useful to what we're
trying to figure out,
because we're trying to figure
out what the velocity is when
you hit the ground, right?
We want to know what the
final velocity is.
We know the initial velocity
is 0, right?
We're just letting it go.
And then what's the
acceleration?
Well the acceleration is
gravity, which is equal to
minus 10 meters per
second squared.
So we could use this formula,
cause we know vi, we know
acceleration, we know change in
distance, so we could solve
for velocity.
So we get vf squared is equal
to vi squared-- well that's
just 0, right-- times 2
acceleration, and so
that's minus 10.
Then what's the distance?
Well the distance is
minus 30, right?
Change in distance
is minus 30.
So you get vf squared is equal
to-- 10 times 30 is 300 is
equal to 600, so if I took 600
square root-- roughly 24.5
meters per second.
So vf is equal to approximately
24.5 meters per second.
Now if we wanted to know well
how long did it did take the
thing to hit the ground, or how
long should it take the
thing to hit the ground.
Well then we could use
this formula, right?
Cause we know the change in
distance, we know the initial
velocity is 0, we know the
acceleration, and so we could
just solve for t.
So change in distance I said
was minus 30, right?
The ball went down 30 meters.
We could say minus 30.
Let me change the colors, cause
I want to make sure you
know which formula I'm using.
I'll do it in that color.
Minus 30 is equal to the initial
velocity of 0-- so the
initial velocity times anything
is 0, so this term
cancels out-- plus at
squared over 2.
So what's a? a is minus 10
divided by 2 is minus 5.
So it's minus 5 t squared.
And so you divide both sides by
5, and you get t squared is
equal to 6.
Once again use the trusty
calculator.
The square root of 6 is
roughly 2.45 seconds.
t is equal to 2.45 seconds.
It's pretty neat.
Using these two formulas
in about 3 minutes.
We probably could do it faster
if we weren't explaining it,
so you could do it really
fast on an exam.
I just said I drop a ball from
a building at 30 meters high.
Very quickly, we were able to
figure out how fast it was
falling when it hit the ground
and how long should it take
for it to fall.
And if I were to give you one
of the other pieces of
information.
If I told you that the ball took
2.45 seconds to fall, and
I didn't tell you the distance,
then you could have
figured out the distance based
on that information using the
same formula.
Hopefully, that makes
some sense.
Actually, I'll leave
it there right now.
I just wanted to show you that
when you actually just go
straight to the formulas, and
you don't do all the kind of
meandering explanations
that I tend to do,
which I do for a reason.
I do them to give you
an intuition.
But when you just go straight
to the formulas, these
problems don't really
take much time.
But with that said, let me
show you how to do it
intuitively if you forget
the formulas.
So once again, I'm
dropping a ball.
It's a 30 meter building,
right?
And I want to figure out what
the speed is when it hits and
how long did it take to fall?
Well let's just start
with our basics.
Let's say I just had amnesia,
and the only thing I remember
is change in distance is equal
to rate times time, or average
rate or average velocity
times time.
And I know that change in
velocity is equal to
acceleration times time,
if I know that my
acceleration is constant.
Otherwise, it would be the
average acceleration.
But this is all you
have to know.
And I'm going to show
you right now.
So we know what the change
in distance is, right?
And just so not to confuse you,
we're doing the exact
same problem.
But I'm just showing you that
you didn't have to memorize
the formulas, although it might
be faster if you do.
So the change in distance is
minus 30 meters, right?
So let's plug that
in straight.
So we know that minus 30
meters-- this is what I'm
going to use-- is equal
to the average
velocity times time, right?
Well what's the average
velocity?
Let's see if we can
figure that out.
Well we know the average
velocity is just the average
of the initial and the
final velocity.
Well what's the initial
velocity?
The initial velocity is 0.
vi is 0.
The final velocity is
the final velocity.
We don't know that yet.
So what's the average velocity
going to be?
It's going to be the average
of these 2 numbers.
So the average velocity is going
to be-- this a little
too bloody, I don't like this
color-- the final velocity
plus the initial velocity
over 2 which
equals vf over 2, right?
So let's put that into
our formula.
So minus 30 is equal to
the average velocity.
That's just the final velocity
divided by 2 times time.
And now you're saying,
but Sal, we
still have 2 variables.
We can't solve for either
one of them, right?
Well if we could write time in
terms of final velocity, then
we could solve for
final velocity.
So let's try doing that.
So let's use this equation
right there.
Change in velocity is equal to
acceleration times time.
What's the change in velocity?
It's the final velocity minus
the initial velocity, and that
equals acceleration.
Acceleration is minus 10 meters
per second squared
times time.
And what's the initial
velocity?
That's 0, right?
So we know that vf-- this is
0-- is equal to minus 10t.
And if we wanted to write the
other way, we could say t is
equal to minus vf over 10.
I just rearranged
this equation.
Now I could take this
and substitute it
back into this equation.
And I get minus 30 is equal to
vf over 2 times t, which is
this right here.
So times minus vf over 10.
And if you solve this, you get,
well you essentially the
exact thing same thing we got
in the previous problem.
You get vf squared
is equal to 600.
I'm skipping some steps just
cause I'm running out of time.
And you get the same answer,
whatever, 24.5 seconds.
I just wanted to do that,
because I wanted to show that
you really just have to memorize
these two things.
And then you can derive all
those equations on the fly,
although it can be faster to
know them ahead of time.
But these are the only
two things that
we're ever really using.
Those other equations are just
derivations of them.
I'll see you in the
next presentation.